hi guys guys guys come on boom I'm Greg
I'm Lauren Lauren Francesca from the
channel I want my Lauren and all of her
social media is a lot of it is all in
the description box so go there follow I
on my Lauren on as many things as you
can CollegeHumor you know alarm is in a
video once for college which was the
video you did ah six girls you dated in
college six girls you dated in college
and also in the photoshop rat ones and
they would always have maybe like a pole
dancer in their video okay HBO GO
sketches whoa yeah well we're gonna
watch a session then don't be pole
dancing today I think it unfortunately
it would have made for a much more
entertaining video but Lauren has more
of a personality than just a pole dancer
we don't watch this video called awkward
at parties horror movie with Allison
Williams who is this more the Stars girl
I start get out awesome and a little rel
and the other guy and get out not sure
all right let's watch it the following
is a fake movie the real movies to get
out these on Tiger is a party
oh sorry
hey babe
I know
overdressed my also right I was creating
a research a lot about nice little why
don't you do this we're new I didn't
realize this rc2 not going to sneak an
Irish take this Alison how is the
business would rather die right here
you didn't betray no well yeah well
happy to see you I just have the most
disastrous experience I'm a man oh my
god i have a place to myself tonight I
got attended a comin somebody finally
swipe right booty oh ok I'm so damn
nobody's [ __ ] deep squeaky you to
subscribe to the channel click here from
adam sup hey sorry guys really kind of
my house I second like I can see the top
of the camera so it is better he's
really tall all right field work ok
thanks a lot how does amazing I really
like that's good not a hilarious man oh
oh the best that's poop I've ever seen
of being awkward at a party or you
offered a party so awkward oh my god are
you offering um it takes me what depends
on if I'm high or I'm not high that
makes the biggest difference we're gonna
party cuz if what I'm hi if I'm meeting
a bunch of strangers I tend to get
really paranoid that like everyone's
judging me like I am picking up on who
thinks I'm high and who is not liking
the fact ok be I just think like I'm
coming across weird or I'm really
self-aware of like oh I feel fat
not funny i have no personality and I
just get so caught up in my head now
even when someone starts talking to me
I'm not even really listening I'm just
going mm-hmm here's a laughing they say
and I ask a question based off that but
like I have a drink or if I'm not high I
said you really well their party yes I
can socialize and have a great time and
dance and stuff so yeah are you the way
what how are you I'm just socially
awkward I don't know like how you feel
when you're high is how I feel all the
time vodka so especially if I go because
I go I go around a lot by myself and
when you're by yourself at a party I
don't know you wanted to people that you
meet but then you don't go like I don't
know when to end the conversation and I
don't know I feel like in my head I'm
like oh my god oh my beaten yeah do
these people want to talk to me I heard
that this um and once to like just some
funny or Die party and I stalking his
group of guys and I all by myself there
and then all sudden and we'll say who
but somebody really famous came in and
they all were like just looking at the
famous person and they were like okay
Larry will talk to you later and I'm
like and they want to talk to the famous
person and I was just like oh wow I just
felt so stupid I was just like oh god I
can do better at parties when it's like
oh these are lying YouTube industry
people or something look like I have
more of a purpose being there uh-huh I'm
really awkward when it's just like no
one knows me and these are just people
see how do you go up to people to talk
to people or then along with somebody
else who knows the people I just think
China like make be friendly and it just
always not yeah is that weird girl
that's with whoever well I'm so far
halfway through the book how to win
friends and influence people I read it
really helped don't believe any of the
[ __ ] anyone's told you about that I
really does say a lot of things and it's
like applying them to your life and
that's the hard part yeah like I
practiced that I feel like I can
definitely have a better conversation
now you just ask questions essentially
what the book is saying we have to know
them on a real level okay and make it
conversation more about them that's a
good that's a good point yeah cuz i I
don't I love it if I could bump into
someone who's okay with just talking all
about themselves cuz then I'm like all
right my job's done I'm asking more
questions we love talking about himself
I get weirder when I have to share about
me and who I
oh yeah that's what book kind of faulted
me because I'm like people who are not
going to be interested in Who I am
because they're only interested in stuff
there's a man sleeping on the floor
right now my dog is that mess a
different sound quality I know you
haven't seen get out yet you heard of it
no get out that movie with uh she's
she's the girlfriend it to the flight
yeah I did ticket yeah it's really
[ __ ] good she has his wife family
obviously and her black boyfriend comes
with her to visit but the whole town and
no family are really weird about black
like they're like it's like spooky
because you're like they don't seem like
they're entirely racist but they seem to
take a weird interest in someone who's
black and weird things start happening
but it shot like the lighting of it
looks like a lot like the actual movie
but little things I put it out of this
thing you know regifting a gift of
similar to give you the hug and the
handshake think I could get weird for me
too I never know what know how to feel
that out yeah wasn't mistaking a guy for
a woman I've done them yeah that happens
that only happens like is it a guy is a
girl I can't handshakes are your weird
about to like let's do handshake hi I'm
Greg right see you like you have a
really gentle one your hand just kind of
stayed like this and you go up and down
uh-huh I like you to grip oh and they
mensa mensa I think when I first met you
you did that and I was just like oh that
really hurt yeah reason I squeezed oh
okay this a little Lou exchanger so yeah
it was a great great sketch CollegeHumor
it wasn't best I've seen in a long time
too bad definitely this is really
[ __ ] hilarious and a great ending on
how she ruined the surprise yeah heart
is reacting i look really loved it may
have both really great in it I fell in
love with Allison Williams gonna watch
that movie oh yeah great girl the key
guy her hair blonde is it blonde in that
movie too no it's brunette I'm knocked
writer's block for a movie now or
something yeah she looks great I like
her as a blonde ha I'm love with her
brunette or blonde Oh she'd married into
it she's actually married to a guy from
collegehumor aloo forgot no no matter
you gonna die soon oh ok cuz I'm more
her type right here curly haired bearded
oh yeah alright guys well
CollegeHumor subscribe to the real
rejects the most importantly subscribe
to Lauren Francesca's channel I want my
Lauren where there's a lot of hilarious
sketches I've been in one I have it in
one I'm into yeah I think you more than
I want the show anyone here within
another one at me none other videos of
you did you shave my back yeah how I got
started thinking yeah yeah which I used
that razor for a very long time till it
broke oh damn it yeah but it really did
come in handy so thank you